Hello Freak bitches.
It's,
it's just so weird.
It's so weird.
We're,
we played in front of half a million people and half a million people,
and this was in Russia.
This was,
uh,
an airfield.
Oh my God.
So we've done that.
What the fuck was that like?
Um,
it was a c c of Russian people.
I mean,
that's what it was.
That's insane.
This was in 1991,
91 91 when the,
you know,
the curtain came down and all of that,
and a Time Warner had a,
uh,
they wanted to basically get their foot in the door.
And so they were created a free concert.
Uh,
it was,
it was a ACDC,
us,
Pantera,
and I think maybe a local band or some other bands.
I'm sorry if,
I can't remember.
But they flew us in there.
We landed in this airfield.
Oh,
Motley crew was on it,
um,
landed in this airfield.
And as far as the eye could see it,
I mean,
it was a free concert and it was just people,
and we get on stage and do what we do.
But there were,
it was military,
you know,
military and the Front Christ,
look at that photo.
Holy Shit.
Jamie.
Go full screen with that.
Okay.
Just go with that one.
What in the fuck.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
Is that it?
Is that the one?
Ooh,
that might be something else,
but it looks a little newer,
but it says here it was from 91 mosque house.
Wow.
Uh,
yeah.
Pretty remarkable.
And there were,
dude,
imagine a sea of people like that and see there's a helicopter helicopter flying
over people.
I mean,
God,
if that thing goes down,
oh it could be chopping up off photo.
Go right up there.
That one on stage facing those people.
All my God,
that is fucking insane.
And that helicopter would come down close and they were yelling at people like,
stop.
You know,
people were marching are going crazy.
They didn't know what that was.
Oh Wow.
I thought it was like a fight.
I freaking communist country man.
And there's like waiting,
people are getting out of order.
This is chaos.
He didn't have the Internet then either.
No Way.
They didn't know what to expect of that.
So are people throwing,
you know,
hitting people from the,
from the helicopter and down in the front there,
there were guys in uniforms,
you know,
there was Lina police military,
same thing,
you know,
so they're standing there in their uniforms and after like three or four songs,
they're like,
fuck this.
And they took off their stuff and then there are the head bang and,
and having a good time.
So we saw the transformation of,
you know,
uh,
closed down society to freedom right before us individually in PR in people.
It was awesome.
Wow.
What does it feel like to stand in front of 500,000 people?
What is the sound like?
What does the sound of their roars like?
Pretty massive.
Um,
obviously,
you know,
I lost count at Latin 300 and something thousand,
but I tell Ya,
and they don't speak your language.
That's just such a,
that's the power of music,
man.
That's a language in its own.
It's connects people.
It is so cool.
So,
yeah,
we went to a place that no one spoke English,
or people were telling us,
you know,
I learned English from your lyrics.
Like,
Oh shit,
man,
I failed English.
Just so you know.
I didn't do so well in school,
but wow.
It's pretty bizarre.
Yeah.
That's intense.
[inaudible].